PAUL SAXMAN: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for joining us.
And if you're joining
us via I/O Extended,
thanks for tuning in.
My name's Paul Saxman.
I'm a Developer Advocate with
the Google Maps Developer
Relations team.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: And I'm
Kasia Derc-Fenske.
And I'm a geo-technical
solutions
engineer for Maps APIs.
PAUL SAXMAN: And today we're
going to talk about ways that
you can use the Google Maps
API to make location
meaningful for your users.
Because from a user's
perspective, location is more
than just a marker on a map.
There are other dimensions
besides where that your users
are likely interested in.
For example, when your users
have to be at a particular
location, what they intend to
do there, and how they're
going to get there can actually
strongly affect the
type of information that you
put on a map, and how you
display the information.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: So to give
you a better idea of what we
mean by that, let me show
you what my calendar
looks like on the map.
I live in Zurich.
And when you have a calendar,
usually calendar events have
locations bound to them.
So it's quite easy to extract
the location, and just put a
pin on the map.
But as you might see, this is
missing a really crucial part
about having things on your
calendar, which is the time.
So if you wanted an app that
was a geo-calendar, which
potentially you can build, you
would need to add the time,
just like I did here.
This gives you a bit
more information.
For example, if you wanted to
find me at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon, you'd know I'd
that I'd be at work.
And it gives me more
information, because I roughly
know what I'm doing
at a given time.
But it's still not everything.
Events have activities, right?
And here I put icons,
because icons are
more visual than text.
And this is a pretty good
overview for me.
If you're a person that is
trying to call me, you might
want to call me when I'm at
work, but you might not want
to call me when I'm attending
my yoga class.
But there's still something
missing, which is
how do I get to places?
So here you can see that I have
an 8:00 AM run schedule I
have it scheduled.
It never happens,
but it's there.
Then I'm biking to work,
which is a red line.
And then I'm taking public
transit to a
wine tasting event.
You know, you wouldn't like me
driving or biking from a wine
tasting event, so it's
quite crucial here.
PAUL SAXMAN: And I kind
of see that you--
it looks like you're going to
have cocktails at your wine
tasting, so it'd be kind of
interesting to see what your
calendar looks like tomorrow.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: It's
Friday night.
It's Friday night.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
So there's actually a lot of
great apps that use multiple
dimensions to make location
meaningful.
These are just a few
of our favorites.
They cover kind of a very
popular, very useful use
cases, like finding a new home
to live in, finding great
food, and actually helping
to plan travel.
But we're not showing you these
to actually discourage
you from building apps that
do these types of things.
I mean, these are actually
really great for inspiration.
We definitely recommend that
you check them out.
But we think that there's
actually a whole kind of class
of use cases that really haven't
been explored yet with
location-based applications.
And that's what we're going
to talk about today.
We're just going to give like
a few examples of kind of
simple ideas that we had for
location-based applications,
and how you can actually use the
Google Maps API to kind of
augment these.
So the first so we're going
to talk about--
our codename was Airporter--
is getting the user to a
particular location on time.
And it's getting them to the
airport, or getting them to
their plane on time.
And so you can imagine that this
is going to be a mobile
application, because the users
are going to want to take--
have the information
on hand as they're
getting to the airport.
And even when they're at the
airport, we can actually give
them information when they're
getting to the terminal.
So we're going to build this
application using the Google
Maps Mobile APIs.
On the left, you have the Google
Maps Android API v2.
And on the right, we have the
iOS Google Maps SDK for iOS.
Both of these were actually
launched late last year, and
they both contain a series of
features that are really great
for building location-based
applications.
A couple really useful ones--
3D buildings.
As you can see in these images,
the buildings are
projected up from the ground.
This is great for giving the
user actually a sense of
perspective, because you can
actually go to street level,
and show them street
level orientation.
The maps actually support
rotation and
tilt, so you can--
north doesn't have to be
at the top of the map.
This is really great for doing
things like plotting paths
around routes.
They also support camera
animations.
So you as a developer can
actually animate transitions
between points on the map.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: But you have
to be careful with that.
If you overdo it, it
can really make
the user feel sick.
So take it easy.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, there's--
you can do some pretty
high-speed
fly-overs if you want to.
Markers and info windows--
this is just plotting simple
location-based
information on the map.
Polygon and polylines--
we'll show those a little bit
later, using polylines for
plotting vector information.
And ground and tile overlays
for putting raster
information on a map.
So there's a number of different
ways you can use
these APIs.
We're going to use it for
building this app to getting
to the airport.
So the first thing you're going
to need to know-- you're
going to need to find
where the user is.
And that's where geolocation
APIs come into play.
The most simplest way to
actually get location
information of the user is using
the MyLocation layer
that's built into the
Maps Mobile APIs.
So these are very
simple to use.
Essentially, just turn the
MyLocation layer on.
You get the blue pin and the
circle, which shows accuracy.
And then you actually just
query the map to get user
location out.
It's simply just two
lines of code--
setMyLocationEnabled.
This is in Java or
Android code.
This is what it looks
like in Objective C.
The great thing about my
location is it does all the
work for you.
You don't have to worry about
what sensors you're using.
how quickly you're going to
get a response back, because
you actually get a response
back fairly quickly.
You also don't have to worry
about plotting the
marker on the map.
The API does all that for you.
The bad thing about MyLocation
is it does all
the work for you.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE:
You said that.
PAUL SAXMAN: What's that?
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Ah, OK.
PAUL SAXMAN: So if you actually
want to customize the
marker, you can't
with this API.
Also, if you want to control
what sensors are active, you
don't have that access with
the MyLocation layer.
But you do have that with
Location Services in the
mobile SDKs or APIs.
Android--
both Android and iOS have APIs
that allow you to actually
control what sensors are being
used, how quickly you get a
response back.
You have a lot more control,
but it's also a lot more
complexity.
And I'll toss this out.
I know we mentioned that we're
doing this on mobile, but
there are HTML5 geolocation
APIs.
You've probably seen this if you
visit a website, and you
get that little yellow bar in
Chrome that says, do you want
to share your location?
Very simple to use.
It's a single line in
JavaScript code.
You get a call back, that you
get the location out once the
user has accepted it.
So on all three platforms--
iOS, Android, and on the web--
are very easy to get user
location to plot on the map.
So once we know where the user
is, we have to figure out
where they're going.
And as Kasia pointed out
earlier, that's where the
calendars are very,
very, very useful.
We can't stress this enough.
I mean, you've probably
seen Google Now.
By the way, the Google Now
actually is giving real-time
information to the user.
And a lot of that information
actually is pulled from
calendar information.
So for example here, you can
see that I have to be at a
flight in about an hour.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Oh no.
You said--
Paul stressed me out the hour,
because I always need two.
And when we rehearsed,
he mentions two.
And now he's stressing
me out again.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Well, you know, it's
flying domestic.
It's a lot easier, I guess,
from flying from Zurich.
But so the calendar actually
has information
about future events.
It has information about where
the users are supposed to be
at the current time.
It also has the information
about where the user has been
historically.
So there's a whole wealth
of information here that
location-based applications
can take advantage of.
And the great news is as well
as that most mobile
platforms--
Android and iOS--
have calendar APIs, or calendar
event APIs, that
allows you to get
the events out.
Also, the Google Calendar has
a web service that you can
access, as well.
So if you want this information,
it's actually
pretty readily available.
Obviously, you have to go
through a whole permission
cycle with the APIs.
But we think these are a great
place to get information about
your users.
The issue is, though, is that
the events in the calendar
don't have--
they're not geocoded locations,
obviously.
They're whatever the
user enters.
Let's say, SFO terminal three.
So at some point, you're going
to have to go from an address
to a marker.
And that's where geocoding
APIs come into play.
So there's mobile geocoders.
On Android and iOS, they can
forward and reverse geocode.
So forward is taking the
address to coordinates,
reverse is taking coordinates
to an address.
Also, the alternative is that
you can use the Google
Geocoding API.
The Geocoding API is
a web service.
Basically, you construct
a URL.
You say if you want the results
in JSON or XML.
You pass in an address,
AND away you go.
The results--
I'm showing you JSON.
The XML looks relatively
the same, just
with more angle brackets.
And this it's pretty
self-explanatory.
This is probably the last slide
I'll actually show you
JSON output, because I generally
think that the JSON
that comes out of the Google
Maps APIs, it's
pretty easy to read.
But you can see where I
had multiple results.
We have geometry information.
We have address information.
Very easy to parse, very
easy to get access to.
So now that we know where the
user's coming from, we know
where they're going, we're going
to actually give them a
little bit of intelligence
when they're
getting to the airport.
So we're going to try to find
the user a place to park.
So you can see here, I've
plotted five markers on this--
or, actually about 10 parking
markers on this map.
So you may have a database if
you're building an application
like this of place
information.
But if you don't, there's
a Google Places API.
So I got this park information
from using Google Places API
Nearby Search service.
Places API is actually-- it's
a suite of search services
they get you access to over 100
million locations, points
of interest, or establishments
that Google has in a database.
And this is the same locations
that you see on Google+ Local
on the Google Maps API.
So querying the Google Places
API Nearby Search service is--
again, it's another
web service.
Kasia's going to talk about
actually the Java script
components-- so a lot of these
a little bit later.
But with Nearby Search, you pass
in location, and most of
the other information
is optional.
So you can specify a radius.
Here I specified
2.5 kilometers.
You can say specify types.
So for example, I just wanted
parking spaces.
There's over 100 different types
available in the Places
API that you can query on, and
you can query on multiple
types if you want.
You can specify a key word.
Here, I'm looking specifically
for airport parking to
differentiate from municipal
parking.
And I've ranked the results by
prominence, which is actually
what we consider kind of
popularity ranking.
The alternate is ranking
by distance.
Another variation of this is
let's say we want to help the
user find a cab.
And so here, what I did is
another Nearby Search.
But here, you can see I'm
actually displaying a bunch of
kind of place information in
this little info window.
That information comes from the
Places API Detail Service.
So the Detail Service--
so with the search services, you
actually get a reference
that you can use to actually
query the detail service to
pull out this information
that you see here.
The Details Service returns
information like, I mean,
obviously, the name of the
place, but information like
the ratings, which is a
five-star scale; price level,
which is a four-dollar sign
scale; phone numbers, you get
both domestic and international
phone numbers.
The addresses are
componentized, if that's a word.
You get opening hours, so you
know when the place is open.
And you actually get a flag to
tell you if the place is open
when you make the query.
You get the place types out.
You get a website URL.
And you also get some
user-generated content,
reviews, and photos.
But we'll talk a little bit
about this later on.
But this is actually the same
kind of reviews and photos
that you actually see in
the Google+ Local.
So let's say the user's
actually picked
their parking lot.
They know how they--
where they want to go.
Now we actually want to give
them some intelligence on how
to get there.
And that's where the
Google Directions
API comes into play.
So you see here, I've plotted a
polyline showing the route.
And I've actually shown the
travel time of 24 minutes.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Come on,
that's not possible.
You're going the 101 there.
24 minutes?
PAUL SAXMAN: We'll touch on
that in a little bit.
Yeah, there's--
101 is, if you're not from
the Bay Area, is
kind of historic mass.
But so the Directions API--
we're going to use the web
service version of it.
Basically, you pass in the
origin and the destination
coordinates.
You specified your mode
of transportation.
What you get out is you actually
get the full route.
You get all the legs in
the route, or the
steps along the path.
You get the full path
information, so you can plot
the polyline.
And you also get the
distance and times
for each of the legs.
So you can actually sum up the
times, or sum the distances,
to give the user intelligence
about how long it's going to
take or how far they
have to go.
However, as Kasia pointed out,
101 actually sees quite a bit
of traffic at certain times.
So this is where the Traffic
layer can be useful.
Traffic layer is available
on all of our APIs--
our mobile APIs and our
JavaScript APIs.
You turn it on with just a
single setTraffictrue, I
believe, in most cases.
And what that does is it
actually plots real-time
traffic information on
the map for the user.
So they can actually see
what the traffic looks
like at that moment.
And then you see that on the
side here, I've actually
adjusted the time.
Now it says 54 minutes.
This is actually a feature
that's available to our Maps
for Business customers.
I mentioned before that the
Directions API returns duration.
But for Maps for Business
customers, they also get
duration and traffic.
So it'll actually calculate how
much time it takes for the
given current traffic.
You can actually do--
set the arrival or destination
time to get future or-- yeah,
to get future traffic
predictions as well.
So let's say the user, they've
seen that ugly traffic on 101.
Potentially they want to
take a train instead.
The Directions API supports
that, as well.
So instead of mode
Driving, you can
actually set mode Transit.
You get the same information
back, all the
steps along the path.
You get all the times
and durations.
You get all--
essentially, everything you see
here, including the names
of the trains, and if
they have to walk
between certain locations.
And the last thing I'm going
to mention-- so let's say
we've gotten the user
to the airport.
They're making a mad
dash to the gate.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: If they have
one hour, that's what
they have to do.
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly.
And you want to give them the
ability to actually find
some-- a healthy snack before
they get on the plane.
So this is where voice
search would--
is very handy.
Voice search is built into
the Mobile APIs.
The user just hits the little
microphone button, they can
actually speak in the phone,
and the phone will do
voice-to-text translation
for them.
But then what do
you do it that?
I mean, they could mutter,
I want cake.
They could say, give me cake
in terminal three.
And that's where the Places
API Text Search
service comes in.
The Text Search service, like
Nearby Search service, takes a
lot of the same parameters,
except it
requires a query parameter.
What the query parameter does
is it will do a natural
language matching based
on the query
string to give you results.
Everything else, like location
radius and types, these are
all optional parameters.
But you can use those to
actually constrain your query.
So since I knew where the
location of user was, since I
know I don't want to give them
food that's over a kilometer
out, I can actually constrain
that, and allow
them to find relevant--
information that's relevant
to them at that moment.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: So cake is
a healthy snack, right?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Actually, when doing this demo,
I actually ran a few
queries for things like, I
don't know, it was like
vegetarian food and salad.
And not to many results in the
San Francisco airport.
So with that, Kasia, you're
going to talk about--
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Yep.
So Paul mentioned events that
are in your calendar.
But the same applies
to bigger events.
Probably all of you know that
May is bike to work month.
And just out of curiosity, how
many people actually bike to
work in this crowd?
OK, well, that's pretty good.
How many people bike to work
during the bike to work day
that was hosted inside
your city?
PAUL SAXMAN: That was during
I/O rehearsals for me.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: OK.
Well, it's not bad.
So what I did is I wanted to
show you how you can use the
power of the Geo
APIs to help in
bigger events and campaigns.
So I built a map to run a
competition between cities for
the bike to work day and
bike to work month.
So if you look here, we have
an address form that uses
place as auto-complete.
We can put in the home address,
which for me was
somewhere in Sunnyvale a week
ago, because that's when San
Francisco had their
bike to work day.
And then you can put
your work address.
And what it does, it simply
counts you as a person that
biked to work.
I agree that there might be some
room for cheating, but
let's leave it as it is.
As you see, you have directions
plotted, and you
have some additional
information.
This is a working demo.
I built it in three hours.
Mind you, it doesn't have a
back-end, so all of the
information of the summaries
are just false data.
So what did we use to
build this demo?
First of all, you saw that when
the user started typing,
they got a bunch
of suggestions.
What we used here is geo-powered
input elements.
Places' auto-complete has a
feature that allows you to
bind to an input field.
And then once the user starts
typing, it provides you with a
list of suggestions.
After they choose a place,
a place change event is
triggered, and you can extract
information about a place.
So here I don't want to ask
users where do they live.
If they gave me their own
address, I can extract the
locality from the place
information.
And I do the same for
the geometry.
PAUL SAXMAN: And there's a web
service for that as well.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Oh, yes.
Yes, of course.
So after the user put in the
information, there were
directions that were plotted.
And it looked in kind
of nice way.
How many people here have
used Styled Maps before?
OK, well, you should
use it more.
Styled Maps are awesome because
they might help you
put a message across.
So here, for example, I used
the Style Map Wizard--
which is the thing you want
to use if you are
styling your map--
to style the map, to decrease
the saturation, and get rid of
some labels.
I mean, I assume that the people
that are putting in
their home address know
the street names
around their homes.
In general, the way maps are
styled is that you specify
element types and
feature types.
They are both character count.
So for example, a feature type
is a road, and a sub-type of a
road is road.highway.
And once the Styled Map produces
styles like this, you
can use it to style the
map in JavaScript.
But you can also tweak
it, because you
see it's quite readable.
What we also did is we put
symbols on the map in the
directions response.
How many people use symbols?
I'd say it's the same amount,
which is quite impressive,
because we only added symbols
about a year ago.
And the power that they have
is they are scalable.
And they're essentially SVG
paths, which you can use to
automate and display things
in an interesting way.
Here we constructed an object,
which is a polylines options
object, where we say what kind
of symbol we want to have on
the polyline.
We are setting the stroke
capacity of the polyline to 0.
We don't want to see
the polyline.
But we want to have arrows
on the polyline.
And after we've done that, we
can simply pass it on to the
directions renderer.
And there's a little thing here
that I also did, which is
suppressing the markers.
Because let's face, you know
where your work is.
So continuing on the demo, we
also had a little panel.
And this is my--
I would like to ask you to
every time that you put
information, such as how long
does it take to go somewhere,
how long is a step of a
journey, what are the
additional--
think about what actually
the user needs.
I mean, you probably know how
much a commute takes.
So here, I displayed to user
some general information.
So instead of running
competition with points and
things like that, and meters,
kilometers, I told them how
many times the bikers from their
city managed to cycle
the earth, and climb
Mount Everest.
And then, I wanted to show them
something interesting.
How many of you know what the
elevation path between your
work and the houses?
Elevation graph.
Really?
Did you attend my rehearsal
session?
Anyway.
This is a piece of information
that is easily achievable
because the direction servers
returns a polyline.
And the elevation service simply
takes the polyline and
a number of samples.
And then you can use the Google
visualization library
and create a common chart
in a really easy way.
You simply add columns, and
then add data rows.
But it's also important to
remember I'm mobile.
I mean, I love JavaScript.
But I admit, you have to think
about mobile, as well.
So here we added a mobile
application that
the users can install.
And if they so wish, they can
show their current location.
And then you can tell which
company they're biking for, or
which city they are biking
for, and collect this
information and put it on
a map using a polyline.
You can then also use this
information to make some
interesting visualizations.
It might be life, or it
might be like here.
Let me just restart it, start
from the beginning.
I simply plotted random points
on the map, because I didn't
have the data.
But this is biking
in San Francisco.
You can see that people
essentially started slow, and
then go a little bit quicker.
And this is, by the way,
using symbols.
And it's a JavaScript demo.
But once you have this
data, you can
use this for a campaign.
But what's really cool is that
you can use the power of data
to help people, and to
make things better.
So remember, plot your data on
the map, and make things
better after you collect
the data.
Here I'm constructing
a live heat map.
But if I switch, you can see
actually the end heat map
overlaid with San Francisco
biking layer, which is also
availability in the API.
And what you can deduce from
here is, for example, that
people are taking a path, which
is not the biking route,
but still a lot of
bikers take it.
And you can go to the city
council, and say, hey, 300
people that day took
this path.
And there's no bike
path there.
Please add it.
And this is a really, really
valuable thing to do.
What's more, if you have this
data, you can, for example,
suggest path updates.
If somebody's going the wrong
way with stupid elevation, and
they have the app installed,
it may suggest to the user,
hey, you can actually choose a
simpler path, and it'll take
you through a nice area.
So I find it really,
really cool.
But enough about
biking, right?
We've been talking
a bit more--
too much about biking.
So let's talk about walking.
We had three demos--
biker, walker, and airporter.
A couple of months back, my
colleague Wolff built a
conceptual demo for an app
that lets you explore the
surroundings.
So what it does is use the
walking transit mode and
directions--
oh, the towns didn't load--
and generates a walking path.
And it's important to remember
that it's also
available on Android.
And this is why we have
this little guy here.
He's a CSS-animated android,
just for the record.
That's why I love HTML5.
So what the application does
is it uses waypoints to
construct a hexagon, which
roughly takes an
hour to walk through.
And it gives you
a walking path.
Then it uses Nearby Search-- the
same as Paul mentioned--
to find places with
given categories.
So I extended the demo
to make it like this.
And also, for example, if you're
in a state agency, and
you want to provide users a way
to learn the surroundings,
you can choose the practical
types here.
And then it'll show you were the
post office is, or where
the nearest shop is.
So with that, let me
show you what the
actual demo looks like.
You input their address.
That's places [INAUDIBLE]
again.
We're on this corner.
Let's say I'm hungry.
I'll choose eat out, and
then click on the map
to generate a walk--
perfect.
Then I have places
with photos.
I'm looking for a place for
food that looks nice.
So let's just scroll
down to see--
the one on the left
here looks good.
Let's go in there.
We have some additional
information.
We have a peg man.
Let's click the peg man.
We're inside.
Isn't that wonderful?
When you have the Place
information, and you set the
stream parameter on, if the
place has Street View, you go
inside, which is pretty
remarkable, I feel.
Let's say I don't want
to walk so much
because I'm pretty hungry.
So I'm making the
route shorter.
Yes, and I'll leave this detour
just for reference.
And yeah, I think
I'm going to go.
Now what I'll do is press the
Share button, which would send
this information to
my mobile phone.
So I get updated as a walk.
And maybe I get Place
reviews read.
But that's for later.
So we have these information,
which is the general
information that Paul spoke
about a bit before.
And you can see it
looks awesome.
If add a panel, a small panel
with Street View-- with your
Street View, it gives a lot more
sense of how the place
looks like.
But we also have--
so this all the information.
Sorry.
This is all the information
you can get
from the Details service.
One particular thing that
I like is the vicinity.
Vicinity is a way to format
an address for locals.
So for example, if you provide
an address, and you're using
Places API, and you know that
the places that people that
will be using this application
are locals, do not have--
make them read through
United States,
California, postal code.
No, just give them the
street and the city.
One additional thing that's
worth noticing
is the opening hours.
So you know when the
place is open.
And yeah, there are plenty of
types, but this is I feel that
this is not the power--
this is not the full power of
the API, because what matters,
as well, is the user-generated
content, right?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, yeah.
So we mentioned it a little bit
earlier that the Places
API gives you access to
user-generated content, as well.
Those are photos and reviews.
So the search services--
actually, for each place
returned, you
get one photo reference.
And the Detail service,
you get up to 10 photo
references, as well.
And these are the same photos
that you see in Google+ Local,
and in the Google Maps API if
you're searching on Places.
So in addition to the
photos, you also
have access to reviews.
So the Detail service-- the
Google Places Details service
will return up to
five reviews.
These are the ones that we think
are the best reviews out
of the bunch.
And you get information such
as the description the user
entered, you get the ratings.
So here, we have actually three
aspects for the ratings.
And also, a attribution so that
you can actually link off
to the person's Google+ profile
if it's available.
And this is what it looks
like actually
in the Detail service--
or, in the JSON for the
Details service.
As you can see with the photos,
you get actually the
height and width information.
You get attribution, so you
can give the user that
generated the content credit.
You see the reviews with
multiple aspects.
For a restaurant, we have
food, decor, service.
Not all places that have
multiple or three aspects.
What we didn't really say is you
can expect there to be at
least one aspect.
And when we have multiple
aspects, the top one is always
the primary aspect.
And then like I said before,
you get the authorship
information, and the text
for the review.
So that's up to five
reviews per place
from the Details service.
So that's pretty much it.
Those are the demos we wanted
to show you today.
So before we go on to Q&A-- so
we're going to have Q&A. You
guys can get up to the
microphones and ask questions
if you want.
We're going to actually check
to see if there's any
questions from online, if
anybody's sending anything our
way from I/O Extended.
And also, we're going to be
in the Sandbox afterwards.
But a few tips for you guys for
getting information, or
getting more information about
what we talked about today.
There's some upcoming sessions
later on today.
I know it's been a long day
already, but at 5:30 we're
going to have a Getting Your
Maps into iOS talk.
I believe that's Mano Marks.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: And Luke.
PAUL SAXMAN: I'm sorry?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, and Luke, yep,
talking about building a
map in iOS.
Tomorrow, there's a bunch of
talks related to what we
mentioned today.
There's visualization talks.
Beyond the Blue Dot is about the
Android location services,
or Android location APIs
that are available now.
And also later in the day,
there's another Android talk,
so about using the
Android Maps API.
And actually, third day, there's
a couple of code labs
you might be interested in.
Definitely check those
out, as well.
There's a lot of resources
you can access online.
This probably isn't
even all of them.
The most important thing you
want to do-- besides a thank
you slide-- go to
developers.google.com/maps.
That's where all the information
that you're going
to want is linked to.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: It recently
had a redesign, so the page
really looks sleek.
It looks sleek.
And check it out.
PAUL SAXMAN: So that's it.
So if you guys have any
questions, feel--
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Should
we take this one first?
PAUL SAXMAN: --free to
step up to the mic.
And again, if you don't want to
ask questions here, we'll
be in the Sandbox
in a little bit.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Feel
free to clap.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL SAXMAN: Now I feel bad.
You had to ask them to.
Oh, that's horrible.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: That was
honest and sincere.
So we have one question
from the online--
PAUL SAXMAN: This guy
looks familiar.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: But that
doesn't even get to--
let's answer this one,
and then queue, OK?
PAUL SAXMAN: Sure.
We're going to take a
question from our
I/O Extended audience.
So the question is, how do you
deal with different address
formats in different
countries?
How does the API handle these?
So actually we have in the
Google Places API is--
actually, most of our APIs--
we have actually the
address components.
So the address is broken apart
into administrative levels--
country, zip codes
or postal codes.
It's pretty--
I'd say it's a pretty
standard format that
kind of maps it to--
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Basically you
can build the format that
you like, that your application
needs from the
components.
And usually, we also try to make
the formatted address and
the vicinity match the
given country.
So when you set the language for
the query, we would try to
return the best formatted
address.
If you don't like it, you
can still change it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So formatted address localized,
the address
components--
you construct it yourself.
But everything is pretty laid
out clearly for you, so.
So yeah, let's take an audience
question, in the front.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys.
I'm Aaron.
And my question was-- so earlier
today, the geofencing
stuff was announced.
And I was surprised you didn't
talk much about it.
What plans do you
have for that?
Part of the talk was predicting
where the user is
going to be, and using
that information.
So do you have anything
special up your
sleeve related to that?
PAUL SAXMAN: We don't really
want to steal their thunder.
The talk is actually tomorrow.
And I definitely recommend
that you go there.
There's a lot of stuff that's
going to be in that talk that
is very relevant to actually
building location-based
applications.
But it is specific to Android.
So definitely go to that talk.
Very cool stuff.
And we're, on the map scene,
very excited that it's
available to Android
developers.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: OK, there's
a question in the back.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hey, you guys.
Is there any plans to have
instead of waypoints to get
their actions, avoid points?
Like, I don't want
to pass here.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Oh, yes.
Actually, the demos that
we saw used waypoints.
AUDIENCE: No, instead
of waypoints.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Instead
of waypoints.
I mean, I want to say the point
I don't want to pass.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Ah, you
don't want to pass.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, so
places to avoid.
I see what you're saying.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: But what I
would suggest that in such
cases, if you specify that you
want route alternatives, you
can get up to three
routes, I think.
So you can use that.
And if it's still passing
through the point that you
wouldn't like to pass through,
simply take the point in close
proximity, and make
it the waypoint.
But another good thing
to do is file a
feature request using--
we have feature tracker
on codedworlds.com.
And we really look for
your feedback.
So if you create a feature, you
find a feature like this--
and a lot of people start, we
actually look at it, and if we
can, we implement it.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Thanks.
PAUL SAXMAN: And not necessarily
avoiding points,
but there's also in the
Directions API, you can
actually avoid-- do things
like avoid toll ways, and
avoid highways.
So if you want to actually
plot a scenic drive, as
opposed to a route up 101,
you can do that.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE:
101 is scenic.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: OK.
Thanks.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there a way with the Places
API to get a place that
corresponds to a textual
address?
Let's say I have an address
in the 1235 Avenue blah.
And I want to know if that's a
place, or what's the place
that corresponds to that.
Is there a way to do that?
PAUL SAXMAN: So, yeah.
So I think that's a really
great use case.
So essentially geocoding,
so you want to--
AUDIENCE: The reverse
lookup, in a way.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Yeah.
Places API does that.
And you can specify
an address.
You get a bunch of places.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, so in your--
I mean, go ahead.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: So I think
with the best solution here is
that Places API is extremely
flexible.
You can look for a place by--
in the query parameter by giving
a URL of a web page,
and it will return the
place information.
You can also give the address,
in which point you might get
more results back.
But if you check the address,
you should simply look for the
matching address.
And it should work flawlessly.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, so the
auto-complete service is a
really great thing
to use as well.
I mean, you can--
it's actually a real-time
service, so the user is typing
it, you're going to
get results back.
But you can actually pass a
full address in there, and
it'll do its best job to find
the match based on how much
information you put in.
So there's a number of different
things you can try.
But I'm pretty sure it's
something one of the APIs and
the Places API will do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: I think
we're short on time.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, we have just
a couple more minutes, so
come on up.
And then like I said, we're
going to head over to the
Sandbox after this, so every
question gets answered.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
This is a two-part question
on reverse geocoding.
So app that we're building
does a lot of reverse
geocoding, tries to take,
let's say, 50 photos the
user's taken that are all
geotagged, and put together
like an itinerary of
where they went--
cities.
And so we're running into
rate-limiting problems,
because we want to do that
processing on the server.
So we've been pushing it off on
the clients so that each of
the clients can do their
reverse geocoding.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
a good idea.
AUDIENCE: But even then, because
we do a lot of waiting
and then syncing all at the same
time, we're still kind of
running into that.
What do you suggest for that?
PAUL SAXMAN: So if you actually
look at our Terms of
Service, we do have
fairly, I'd say,
generous caching policy.
So you are able to cache
information.
It's up to 30 days.
You have to cache it securely,
and you have to refresh it
regularly, and that's within
that 30-day time frame.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Did
you also enable
billing in the API console?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I can't
remember if we
did that yet or not.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: So actually,
if you enable
billing,, you get a higher quota
for the service side.
But if you don't-- until you
reach a certain limit, you
will not get charged for that.
So come up to us, and we can
explain how to set it up, and
how does it work.
If you're overusing your quota,
you can always try to
reach out to us to get
a business license.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
PAUL SAXMAN: We'll do--
actually, we just have two more,
and then we'll mosey
over to the sandbox.
AUDIENCE: OK, hi guys.
I have one question regarding
your Android API.
Is there any possibility to add
gradient information to a
vector-based route drawing
at the moment?
PAUL SAXMAN: Can you
repeat that please?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the Android API.
Is there any possibility to add
gradient information to a
vector-based route drawing?
PAUL SAXMAN: A gradient?
So elevation?
So the Elevation API that
Kasia showed in the web
application, there's
a web service
equivalent to that as well.
AUDIENCE: No, I don't mean.
I think that you can use
different colors for different
points in the route?
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Essentially,
there are overlay
in the Android API.
So you can draw your own--
AUDIENCE: That's rasterize.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: You have
to convert, yeah.
So it's up to your own
resources to draw
vector data for now.
You can build an overlay
using your raster data.
PAUL SAXMAN: I've seen one app
that actually does a really
nice job of that.
I've kind of lost it off
the top my head.
But they're essentially
doing that.
AUDIENCE: It's called Urban
Testing bike apps,
because it's ours.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, basically you draw the
polyline and do it in a bitmap
on Android.
And then you actually can
convert that into either a
tile overlay or a
ground overlay.
Tile overlay, you get
better zoom control.
AUDIENCE: We're using with
the tile overlay.
PAUL SAXMAN: Perfect.
Yeah, that's generally
the route.
I mean, I think we do have a
feature request open for this,
for a kind of multi-color
polylines.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: And you can
also build this yourself and
then upload it somewhere
so that other
developers can use it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Actually,
we have-- we're
actually over time.
So maybe last question, we'll
take it over in the Sandbox,
if that's OK.
AUDIENCE: Short question
possible?
PAUL SAXMAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The user remarks in
the Places API, they tend to
be in different languages.
Is it possible, according to the
locale of the device, to
sort them out?
So you have a French person
using, he only
gets the French comments.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Oh, it's with
the language I think this
is not possible yet.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, that one
I'd have to do a little
research on.
I don't that's possible off
the top of my head.
But if you can join us over
the Sandbox, we can do a
little bit of research.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
KASIA DERC-FENSKE: OK.
Thank you so much for
attending, guys.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah,
thanks again.